e se nós não vos os meros espectadores
ou treinadores de bancada da nossa
própria vida e se em alguma área de
desenvolvimento
nós temos um caminho muito árduo
o fundo está vivendo às vezes maior
brincar
somos os primeiros oito anos até por
cento mais à vontade pra minha vida meu
trabalho há seis meses em maio a seis
meses
e trabalha com uma experiência design
exemplo que o livro vai uma experiência
online
eu queria pensar o tempo todo a gente
pergunta o que isso tem a esperança de
medalha
quando eu vou explicar a de fazer sombra
a mãe design é o design de experiências
normalmente o design é um design do
objeto tangível trabalha com os fados
uma mesa ou design nacional do acre por
exemplo o de várias experiências é o
design de uma experiência eu seja uma
situação pode ser por exemplo a
experiência de irmos américo trabalhar
no canal existente 30 antes que é
popular medicina ficou nos tempos de
menina de gênero em trabalhava isso é
como ir ao médico essa dimensão já era
por exemplo pode ser também a
experiência de cooperação entre os dois
países
esse projeto é o turismo como dois
eventos para criar com os países neste
caso os países na zona do báltico
ou pode ser a experiência de
entretenimento para por exemplo o
projeto foi objeto das obras de empresas
é o fato de nós tentarmos ver um
problema ou uma situação vista de franz
tentar ter um ponto de vista e levado
para conseguir ver o problema como a
certa distância em todo o sistema a
volta desse problema que eu estava aqui
com vocês
motiva a experiência semelhante
485 mil pessoas deixaram portugal entre
2011 e 2014
485 mil pessoas
imaginemos o estádio do dragão cheio pés
news
tanto eu diria
além de muitos outros que estão lá fora
chegou perto dos 5 milhões
desta forma poderemos viver portugal é é
um especialista do país mas também é
preciso que a subida não vejo que não é
o seu
isso tudo é conhecimento sobre a
experiência e grande conhecimento para
gerar valor para o país isso que os
azuis
criamos melhorar as coisas vão mudar as
coisas para realmente tomar um caminho
que o neymar dentro da área que a
imigração
talvez uns dois três meses estava lá
ae
a europa do sul
os ovinos de corrupção está em várias
caminhadas
respirar fundo e contar até dez e os
risos
expliquei que não concordava que nós
como emigrante português podíamos
aprender com a suécia
as pessoas têm também aprendi muito com
portugal na experiência dentro do
espelho de troca entre os dois países
mas também só trocou manda entre as
pessoas o que acontece em portugal
infelizmente meu ver é que também é
comum ouvir comentários deus todos nós
já ouvimos este tipo de comentários no
facebook já embora nós somos muitos
só nos últimos anos entre 2011 e 2014
todos nós eu estava fora uma namorada um
marido alguém próximo da família na
escola comentários públicos comentários
estas pessoas que estão lá fora e ouvir
e divulgar este pensamento
vários estudos também viver por exame
gráfico o centro
sundar não deixar a europa ea américa do
norte e vou pensar em si e na ásia por
exemplo o então o porto que em portugal
os integrantes mais empreendedores
portugueses mas não quero utilizar no
caso pessoal minha experiência pessoal
com um exemplo disso é o design em que
eu participei em 2012
eu não estava a estudar na suíça estava
a tirar um extrato e esta competição é
uma conquista de jovens talentos do
design escandinavo trabalhavam durante
alguns meses como mentores também na
escandinávia e depois da aposentadoria o
projeto na vitória que foi a designer
helsínquia
o projeto era nós tínhamos planear
comecei ao futuro em 2030 identificar um
problema nessa tudo e apresentar uma
solução para esse problema
mas minha condição porque estava a
apresentar as fazia
porque senão não teriam chance que é
porque banda poison portuguesa porque
estava lá estava a estudar lá tive essa
oportunidade certa forma ganho este
prémio é a oportunidade que as
oportunidades devem ser dadas
acho que não gostar dos jogos finais
para vencer as águias mas entendeu que
deu a conhecer o facto de nos dar a
oportunidade acho que nossos emigrantes
que estamos lá fora que iremos retribuir
a suécia é um país que sabe muito bem a
diferença
sabes ler suas que são outros países
mesmo com o aumento de determinados
grupos e partidos radicais e cho mix dão
oportunidades também contribuído
organizar com os meus amigos
em 2003 o brasil que é o fio ao cinema
brasileiro com a minha linha que une
rock in rio e pensamos fizesse uma coisa
destas fotografias
começamos com alguns dias como alguns
dias era em uma semana inteira em nota
buru e também onde os convidados
portugueses realizou dois escritores
divulgar a cultura portuguesa
temos também crianças com animação
portuguesa tanto nos funções como vamos
animação portuguesa às escolas
esta equipa do restelo não está completa
somos alguns nós em cinema uma forma
brilhante a meu ver de porque a luz à
nossa cultura como podemos contribuir à
suécia começou a ser registrada na
oportunidade que nos dá atribuídos como
atenas e não vê no cinema é uma forma
muito boa
representar a nossa cultura temos a
língua temos a música tema das paisagens
de luz gêmeos em portugal
todo o conhecimento que tem a nível de
imigração não só do ponto de vista nós
somos nós
meu pai está presa
nós temos aqui uma sala cheia de pessoas
mudanças a fazer uma diferença que nós
sejamos para esta mudança por mais
sociais nunca o desconhecido e os
diferentes nunca assustar a nossa
história e não ia ser agora